at cspan.org
now author jefferson morley and lawrence
wilkerson the former chief of staff to
secretary of state colin powell
discussed the history of israel's
security strategy at a day-long policy
conference hosted by the institute for
research middle eastern policy and
american educational trust
this is almost an hour
all right we have the last panel and
it's going to be a really interesting
one
about u.s
american foreign policy
so jefferson morley will speak first and
he'll talk about the cia and mossad
trade-offs in the formation of the u.s
israel strategic relationship
jefferson morley is a veteran washington
investigative reporter and the author of
the ghost the secret life of cia spy
master james jesus engleton which is
flying off the shelves of our middle
east books and more bookshelves he'll be
signing his books at five o'clock
his latest must read book sheds new
light on angleton's close relationship
with israeli intelligence citing such
cases as israel's 1967 attack on the uss
liberty and the diversion of u.s
government-owned weapons-grade uranium
from apollo pa to israel in the 60s
a native of minneapolis
morley attended yale university and
worked as an editor at the newer
republic the nation and spin magazine
but before joining the washington post
in 1992 where he worked for 15 years his
reporting has appeared in the new york
review of books reader's digest the new
york times book review rolling stone the
los angeles times the american prospect
and so on you're going to want to buy
his book after hearing his talk
thank you welcome
thank you delinda and thank you all for
coming
uh
thanks to grant for inviting me
thank you gideon nora and ali who i made
friends with for the first time last
night thank you for being my friends
this is my first time
at this conference and everybody has
made me feel very welcome
thanks to to our live stream audience
for paying attention please share this
video on social media
you have your orders push that thumbs up
button early and often
since the publication last october of
the ghost my biography of james angleton
i've spoken to many people all over the
country about this protean unique and
some would say sinister character
but i don't think i've ever spoken to a
group this large so thank you all for
coming
um if you do like this talk i hope
you'll buy the book in fact i've been
told that it's an iron law of this
conference that if you like the book you
are obliged to purchase the book so i'll
be signing uh here afterwards and you
know what to do
james angleton's story is a story for
the ages but it's also a story of our
time and i want to emphasize that in
sketching a little bit about him
personally and especially the very
earliest days of the us israeli
relationship
when i started writing the ghost in
january 2015 the term the deep state was
pretty much unknown publicly saved to a
handful of political scientists
and when i finished the book two years
later in the spring of 2017
i was informed by an abc news poll that
48 percent of americans agreed that
there is such a thing as the deep state
which was defined as military or
intelligence officials who secretly
manipulate u.s policy
i realized that angleton
who was a cold warrior and a zealous
defender of america's leadership role in
the post-war world
was also an avatar of this so-called
deep state and i don't mean that in a
kind of conspiratorial or spooky way i
mean that in a very specific and
concrete way
angleton embodied and shaped the cia's
operational ethos and its internal
procedures
especially in the realm of counter
intelligence
his theories of soviet penetration
dominated the thinking of western
intelligence agencies and their legacy
can even be seen in the
counterintelligence investigation into
the trump campaign and allegations of
collusion with russia
i want to emphasize that i only use the
term deep state as a colloquial
shorthand term for the array of u.s
national security agencies
that operate under the shroud of
official secrecy
and let's not forget there are a dozen
at least a dozen such agencies based
here in washington the cia with its 15
billion a year budget is the largest
the nsa with a budget of about 10
billion is second largest
the defense intelligence agency is about
4 billion
and then along with some other
obscure but still very large agencies
like the ngia
never heard of the ngia i didn't think
so
the national geospatial intelligence
agency is a uh
4 billion 4.9 billion a year agency
collectively these agencies spend
probably 50 to 60 billion dollars a year
which make them a very small but
powerful potent sector in the american
scheme of power
want to know how the ngia spent your 4.9
billion dollars
good luck
want to see a line item budget of cia
activities in africa last year you know
move along
it's true that congress nominally has
oversight powers over these agencies
our elected officials do have the
security clearances that we don't have
so they can go in and look at selected
operations
but the intelligence oversight system is
very weak as even its defenders will
admit the intelligence committees
polarized and politicized can't even
agree on what kind of secret activities
they're supposed to monitor
the fisa court system
is supposed to protect americans from
surveillance by their government but it
largely functions as a rubber stamp of
the secret agencies
secret government is the norm in america
in 2018
which is why the discourse of the deep
state has such currency today
angleton i'm going to put to you was a
founding father of what we call the deep
state
so who was he
born in 19 december 1917 james angleton
grew up as the oldest son of james hugh
angleton
a brash self-made american businessman
who moved to milan italy
during the depression
and made a fortune
during the time of benito mussolini
selling cash registers
angleton
attended private school in england he
went to yale college and then to harvard
law school
he was a precocious good-looking young
man with sophisticated manners and a
literary frame of mind
as an undergraduate he befriended his
fellow ex-patriot ezra pound in italy
pound was the modernist poet and the mad
tribune of mussolini's fascism
in their correspondence which i found at
yale um angleton sometimes aped the
anti-semitic rhetoric of ezra pound for
example criticizing the jewish book
merchants who he thought overcharged for
pounds books
in 1943 angleton was recruited into the
office of strategic services
america's first foreign intelligence
service stationed in rome during and
after world war ii he excelled at secret
intelligence work i tell the story in
the ghost of how he rescued several a
leading nazi and a leading italian
fascist from post-war justice
among other tasks he reported on the
flow of jews escaping from uh germany
and heading for palestine
the revelations of the holocaust
transformed his attitudes
towards
transformed his disdain for jews into
something of sympathy
he began to develop sources among the
leaders of
the jewish and zionist organizations
including teddy kollik who was a british
intelligence agent and a german
operative named arthur pierre who later
became known as
asher ben natan
with the passage of the national
security act in july 1947 angleton went
to work at the cia cia came into
existence and angleton became the chief
of the foreign intelligence staff
with responsibility for intelligence
collection operations worldwide
in those days the cia was right here in
the heart of washington it's hard for
people to believe now but the cia was
located in a series of temporary
buildings located along the reflecting
pool uh next to the um next to the
lincoln memorial
the the tempos as they were called by
cia people were
drafty in the winter
hot in the summer and devoid of charm
year round but this is where the
angleton worked at what was known as the
office of special operations
engleton while sympathetic to jewish
suffering was still very wary of israel
when he started his career at the united
at the cia before the 1948 war the
jewish army had been largely armed by
czech arms manufacturers and communist
czechoslovakia the soviet union was the
first country to recognize the state of
israel in 1948 and angleton initially
feared that the soviets would use israel
as a platform for injecting spies into
the west
the israelis for their part were looking
to cultivate american friends stalin's
anti-semitic purges in 1948 showed that
his uh allegiance to the jewish state
was superficial at best
in 1950 a man named reuven shaloa
the founder of israel's first
intelligence organization came to
washington and he visited the cia and he
came away very impressed with how it was
uh organized
he went back to israel and in april 1951
he created out of a very fractious
collection of security forces uh what
was known as the institute for
intelligence and special tasks
inevitably known as mossad hebrew for
institute
in 1951 prime minister david ben-gurion
came to the united states and brought
shiloha with him
ben gurion met privately with
president truman and angleton arranged
for ben gurion to also have lunch with
his friend alan dulles who would shortly
become the director of the cia
the purpose of this meeting efram halevi
a retired director of the mossad and a
longtime friend of angletons told me in
an interview in tel aviv
the law the purpose was in hillevi's
words to clarify in no uncertain terms
that notwithstanding
what had happened between israel and the
united states in 1948 and
notwithstanding that russia had been a
key factor in israel's survival
israel considered itself part of the
western world and would maintain the
relationship with the united states
in this spirit
shiloh stayed on in washington to work
out the arrangements with angleton
shaloa according to his biographer soon
developed a special relationship quote
unquote and angleton became the cia's
exclusive liaison with the mossad in
1951.
engleton returned the favor by traveling
to israel often
he was introduced to amis manure
chief of counter-espionage for israel's
domestic security service known as
shabbat or shin bet
manure headed up operation balsam which
was the israelis conduit to the
americans
quote they told me i had to collect
information about the soviet bloc and
transmit it to them manure recalled
about the americans i didn't know
exactly what to do but i had the idea of
giving them material we had gathered a
year earlier about the efforts of the
eastern bloc to use israel to bypass an
american trade embargo we edited the
material and informed them that they
should never ask us to identify our
sources
from such arrangements the c i a massage
relationship began to grow
manure would be friends with angleton
for the rest of his life
in 1963 a man named issa harel succeeded
uh as uh was succeeded as the chief of
mossad by a military intelligence
officer named maya ramit
amit
angleton to be a little eccentric but he
noted that his quote identification with
israel was a great asset for israel
asher ben natan angleton source dating
back to the oss days was playing a key
role procurement role in the secret
israeli program to obtain nuclear
weapons
teddy kollik one of angleton's closest
contacts and friends in washington later
became the mayor of jerusalem
angleton's israeli friends in short were
really the architects some of the
architects of the zionist state
as i learned that came to learn this
story from talking to cia veterans and
israelis and and reading a lot a couple
of things stood out to me first of all
the israeli recruitment of angleton was
extremely astute in the early 1950s
engleton was a rising star at this new
agency the cia
but he was not a senior figure and not
even particularly powerful the israelis
recognize the latent qualities that
would make him powerful
second angleton's creative intellect and
his operational audacity inspired deep
feelings of loyalty among the israelis
while angleton's counterintelligence
vision would become very controversial
within and bitterly divisive within the
cia he was widely admired in israel
as a stalwart friend
and he still is to this day
in 1954 angleton became the chief of the
cia's counterintelligence staff the
first one in 1956 amis manure passed him
a copy of nikita khrushchev's secret
speech to the soviet communist party
in which he criticized the cult of
personality around the deceased dictator
joseph stalin
this intelligence coup made angleton a
legend within the cia and power within
the agency as well
and it was very much made possible by
the israelis
angleton's formative and sometimes
decisive influence on u.s policy towards
israel can be seen in many areas from
the impotence of u.s nuclear
nonproliferation policy in the region to
israel's triumph in the 1967 six-day war
to the feeble u.s response
to the attack on the liberty to the
intelligence failure represented by the
yom kippur war of 1973
i tell a lot of this story in the ghost
but the story of angleton in israel is
really so large and so profound that it
probably deserves its own book
i could certainly not do justice to it
in the 18 minutes that i have so i'm
going to confine myself to one narrow
question about the trade-offs that
became implicit in this
agreement
in this arrangement between the cia and
the mossad and its implications for us
and the question uh which was put to me
by grant but is right on point was
why didn't the cia help the fbi
investigate the diversion of u.s weapons
grade material from the united states to
israel in the 1960s and 1970s
and the short answer is because jim
angleton didn't want to
um
angleton played a key role in enabling
israel to obtain nuclear weapons and he
did so in a subtle way that
characteristically left few fingerprints
he was not a man to investigate himself
many of these details are now known
thanks to grant smith roger matson john
hadden jr and others
i want to just
give you a sense of of how this
transpired so the nuclear materials and
equipment corporation otherwise known as
numec started processing highly enriched
uranium in the united states in 1959.
numec had been created by david
lowenthal a zionist financier who
financed the post-war
boat lift from europe to palestine that
was romanticized in the book and movie
exodus
he hired zalman sapiro
zalman shapiro a brilliant young
metallurgist to run the company
at that time the us government owned all
of supplies of nuclear fuel which
private companies like numec were
allowed to use but ultimately had to
return to the government
within a few years the atomic energy
commission noticed worrisome signs that
the apollo plant uh
numec had a plant in apollo pennsylvania
that the plant's security and accounting
were very deficient
unexplained losses did happen of nuclear
material did happen at other companies
at other companies but new mex losses
were proportionally much larger
um by october 1965 the aec estimated
that 178 kilograms of highly enriched
uranium had gone missing from the new
mech facility
by march 1968 that figure was
267 kilograms
john hadden was the cia station chief in
israel from 1964 to 1967 and worked very
closely with angleton throughout this
period
and he would later concur with the near
unanimous assessment of cia's nuclear
scientists that israel had indeed stolen
fissile material from numec and used it
to build their nuclear arsenal
this story is now very well documented
in the spring of 1965 a technician
working at the night shift at numec went
out on a loading dock for a breath of
fresh air
and saw an unusual sight
zalman shapiro was pacing on the dock
while a foreman and truck driver loaded
cylindrical storage containers known as
stove pipes onto a flatbed truck
the technician saw a clipboard saying
that the material was destined for
israel
it was highly unusual to see dr shapiro
in the manufacturing section of the
apollo nuclear facility the technician
said it was unusual to see dr shapiro
there at night and it was very unusual
to see dr shapiro so nervous
the next day new mex personnel manager
visited the technician and threatened to
fire him if he did not keep his mouth
shut that's a quote concerning what it
would be seen what he had seen
it would be 15 years before the employee
told the story to the fbi
what did angleton know about numec well
he knew that the a that the aec and the
fbi were investigating starting in 1965
as the israel desk officer the cia he
talked about the numec case with liaison
agent sam papich who was monitoring the
investigation for the fbi
he also spoke about it with his
colleague john collin john had
on the crime scene particulars hadn't
defended his former boss
quote any suggestion that angleton had
helped the israelis with the numec
operation was totally without foundation
he told journalists andrew and leslie
coburn
but hadn't didn't deny that angleton had
helped the israeli nuclear program
why would somebody whose whole life was
dedicated to fighting communism have any
interest in preventing a very
anti-communist nation from getting the
means to defend itself hadn't asked
the fact they stole it from us didn't
worry him in the least he went on i
suspect that in his inmost heart he
would have given it to them if they had
asked
hadden knew better than to investigate
any further i never sent anything to
angleton on this the nuclear program
because i knew he wasn't interested
hadn't later told his son and i knew he
tried to stop it if i did
with the fissile material diverted from
new mech israel was able to construct
its first nuclear weapon by 1967
and become a full-blown nuclear power by
1970
the first and still the only nuclear
power in the middle east
angleton it is fair to say thought
collaboration with israel was more
important than u.s non-proliferation
policy and he believed that the results
proved his point
when he started as chief of the
counterintelligence staff in 1954
the state of israel and its leaders were
regarded warily in washington especially
at the state department
when angleton left government service 20
years later israel held twice as much
territory as it had in 1948 the cia and
mossad collaborated on a daily basis and
the governments of the united states and
israel were strategic allies knit
together by expansive intelligence
sharing multi-billion dollar arms
contracts and coordinated diplomacy
angleton's influence on u.s israeli
relations between 1951 and 1974
exceeded that of any secretary of state
with the possible exception of henry
kissinger
his influence was largely unseen by
congress the press other democratic
institutions and much of the cia itself
he was empowered by his own ingenuity
and the clandestine arrangements
rationalized by doctrines of national
security and counterintelligence
the arc of his career breathes life into
the concept of the deep state
i thought of this story when i visited
one of the memorials to angleton in
israel
in 2016.
the memorial is located on a winding
road outside the city of mevocerezione
which is now really a suburb of
jerusalem
historically control of this high ground
has been seen as key to the control of
jerusalem and of palestine itself
and the nearby ruins of a castle built
by 12th century christian crusaders for
exactly that purpose
stands in mute testimony to its
strategic the importance of its
strategic location
the angleton memorial consists of a
pedestal of stones topped with a black
plaque
to james
angleton
a friend it says
this plaque was dedicated in 1987 a few
months after angleton died and it has
been maintained by his israeli friends
ever since it's still in perfect
condition
the location is no accident in the
course of his extraordinary career
angleton more than any other american
enabled the americans to gain and hold
the strategic high ground in the middle
east
he was as his friend meyer amit said the
biggest zionist of the lot
thank you
[Applause]
colonel wilker lawrence wilkerson is up
next and his bio is incredibly long and
he has a lot to talk about so i'm going
to shorten it he is going to talk about
um is the u.s ramping up its military
presence in syria and preparing to
attack iran for israel
and his last position
to the in the government was as
secretary of state colin palace chief of
staff from 2002 to 2005
and
before serving okay i'm really
shortening it um
before serving at the state department
wilkerson served 31 years in the u.s
army
and he retired from active service in
1997 as a colonel and has taught
national security affairs in the honors
program at george washington university
and you're currently
distinguished visiting professor of
government and public policy at the
college of william mary in williamsburg
and you're working on a book about the
first george bush administration welcome
thank you
and thank you all for being here i'm the
last speaker i get that distinction
if this were a military audience i'd ask
you to stand up and do five minutes of
calisthenics
[Laughter]
just to make sure you don't doze off
i have to identify myself with the
remarks that were just made
over some 400 students graduate and
undergraduate and 12 years on two
university campuses in six years with
about a thousand students at two of the
nation's most prestigious war colleges
we have determined
although it would be probably difficult
to prove and that's the reason we have
covert operations
that lyndon johnson not only knew
the gory details of the israeli attack
on
uss liberty in the eastern mediterranean
he also knew about what was just told
you
as to say he knew
the uranium was being diverted he knew
israel was building a bomb and he chose
not to do anything about it
that's not my subject today
although i could talk for on that sort
of thing forever as i'm sure jefferson
could too
these days
i believe one gets the best insights
into israeli security policy and perhaps
even into israeli policy writ large
which you've heard a lot about today
from the russian immigrant to israel a
former foreign minister and now its
defense
minister
uh avigdor lieberman
whether it's his calling arab members of
the knesset war criminals
or declaring the jewish people should
leave france
or claiming that the next military
action against hamas in gaza will be the
last
or contradicting his own military chief
by denying there is a humanitarian
crisis in gaza
or stating categorically that the idf
will stop at nothing in order to win
reminding me a great deal of dick cheney
lieberman is the living face of bibi
netanyahu's zionist policies
i sometimes think he would have rather
remained in russia
so long as it was the soviet union and
as so long as he were in a significant
position of power there
in addition to reminding me of cheney
he is reminiscent of and indeed might
well be a late version of joseph stalin
as an aside it is intriguing
and i think well outside the usual
conspiracy theory
to consider whether or not lieberman has
been intimated of our own president
trump might be an nkvdg are you kgb fsb
you name it plant
that is an agent of vladimir putin he
has more or less forged most of the one
million russian immigration
since 1991 into a formidable political
force forming the political party that
has more than once played king maker in
the israeli political scene
what a
strategic coup
for vladimir the master chess player in
the world today in my estimation while
everyone else plays a really lousy game
of checkers
it would be quite a coup for him
a far more concern at the moment and
readily provable unlike what i just said
lieberman exemplifies where israel is
headed
toward a massive confrontation with the
various powers arrayed against it
a confrontation that will suck america
in
and perhaps terminate the experiment
that is israel
and do irreparable damage to the empire
that america has become
lieberman will speak in april in new
york city at the annual conference of
the jerusalem post the title is
quote the new war with iran
unquote
it is clear that he's in the forefront
of promoting this war
and nowhere does my concern about such a
war focus more acutely at the moment
than in syria
as president of france
emmanuel macron described it recently
quote the current rhetoric of the u.s
saudi arabia and israel is pushing the
region toward conflict with iran unquote
in that triad no state is doing that
more than israel
listen to netanyahu in january at the
holocaust memorial museum in jerusalem
quote
the greatest danger that we face of
hatred for the jewish people and the
jewish state comes from iran it comes
from the ayatollah regime that is
fanning the flames of anti-semitism
unquote
this anti-anti-semitism bid of course as
we've heard today almost always a weapon
of choice for israeli politicians under
stress
hurled in this case at the country whose
jewish population by the way the largest
in the middle east outside turkey and
israel lives in iran in reasonable peace
and don't forget that these words are
uttered by the man who is as we've heard
here today briefly doing everything he
can to expel dark-skinned african
refugees largely from eritrea and the
sudan from israel where most have come
as legitimate refugees president trump's
wall on the mexican border is nothing
compared to bibi's actual policies
more recently bibi's performance at the
munich security conference
bordered on the infantile
and yet effective when you think about
the audience to whom he's speaking as he
held off an alleged piece on an alleged
iranian drone and asked monsieur zarif
if he recognized it
of course mr reef later
took his occasion at the microphone to
characterize netanyahu's performances
like that of a circus clown
pretty good characterization as a matter
of fact
but i like the comment of lebanon
lebanon's defense minister even better
it went to the point he said that he had
an israeli drone over his head virtually
24 7.
that comment put the hypocrite that
netanyahu is
in the right perspective
of late of course tel aviv is
increasingly using iran's presence in
syria its support for president bashar
al-assad
and its alleged drive and i love this
one my military comrades love it too for
a shia corridor
from tehran to aiden
as the hoary beast that must not be at
any cost
including of course american treasure
and lives
as his probable cause an existential
prompt for action
that israel has in support such
disparate figures as nikki haley at the
united nations
jim mattis at the pentagon rex tillerson
at state as well as the usual suspects
from outside the world of warmed over
neoconservatives
is indicative of such policy but it's
not just the usual suspects from the
world of neocons
about whom i know quite a bit having
experienced them in 2001 and two and
three
take for example my south carolinian
fellow south carolinian lindsey graham
speaking four days ago after a
breathless trip
to israel
a bipartisan trip he called it i don't
know how anybody could use that term
and i cautioned uh you know don't laugh
because lindsay was serious i think
but anything bipartisan with regard to
israel
call it unanimity call it absolute union
enemy anything but bipartisan
in fact the proper words are probably
overwhelming and unprecedented unanimity
in fact the only issue that does unify
the united states congress other than
mom and apple pie
but graham had this to say
quote
anytime you leave a meeting where the
request is ammunition ammunition
ammunition that's probably not good
that's lindsay that's lindsey i didn't
know lindsay well
this was the most unnerving trip
i've had in a while he said breathlessly
again
graham went on to assert that quote when
they tell you when they tell you we want
help to deal with the blowback that
might come from attacks on civilian
targets where where hezbollah has
integrated military
capabilities that was so striking that
was striking on end of quote
and then senator coons
who up until this time i've had some
respect for
fairly sane and sober senator from
delaware reported that quote the tempo
in terms of potential for conflict in
syria has gone up astronomically the
technologies iran is projecting into
syria and southern lebanon has gone up
iran's willingness to be provocative to
push the edges of the envelope to
challenge israel has gone up end of
quote
coons reported this almost as
breathlessly as lindsay
with the highest technician
highest tech nation on earth in syria
the united states of america
that is all coons could derive from his
visit
that the country that spends less than
one percent of what the u.s spends on
its national security
has introduced new technologies in syria
technologies that threaten the country
israel to whom the u.s bounty is
limitless
this is joseph gebbel's territory
karl rove is envious
foundation for the defense of
democracies as the heir to the project
for a new american century bill
crystal's iraq bound think tank
leads that pack of wolves disguised as
warmed over neocons lavishly funded by
the likes of paul singer
it's even spawned the institute for the
study of war a fascinating orwellian
title if there ever was one it should be
the institute for war
i've been asked why is it that you
ascribed to ftd and now the isw such
nefarious motives i was asked this by
the new york times editorial staff when
they published my op-ed on iran a few
days ago
my answer is simple
because that is precisely what fdd is
attempting to do
just as douglas feis
under secretary of
defense for policy
office of special plans did in 2002 and
2003 for richard bruce cheney to lead us
into war with iraq i've been there done
that i don't need the tour
the salient question though
why do you believe that america is
headed for a struggle with iran
needs an answer
certainly america's unquestioning
support
is required
as has been the case from george w bush
to barack obama to the rapture seeking
mike pence and the tweeter and king
donald trump
but it seems that recently
lieberman and netanyahu and their
acolytes in this country amongst which i
put at the top nikki haley
have determined that it would be best if
american troops
also participated in the overthrow of
the tehran regime
from one point of view i suppose this is
understandable the crashly opportunistic
point of view that is that better to
squander your own allies blood and
treasure than your own
but it's certainly not in the character
that i'm used to
with regard to the state of israel and
certainly not with regard the israeli
defense force
that that force could handle anything
iran through at it militarily is
undeniable
any military professional will tell you
that and that israel's more than 200
nuclear warheads
could decimate iran is equally
undeniable
so why this attempt to suck america
into this conflict
i believe the answer is fairly clear
once you push aside the cobwebs
that surround it
the legitimacy of great power is what i
call it
and that is precisely what netanyahu and
lieberman desire it's also what riyadh
desires especially with the new boy king
mohammed bin salman
now an erstwhile ally of israel
in short
the idf could defend israel but could it
it could not attack iran not successful
anyway
and worried to do so it would be damned
internationally and thus isolated even
more than it already is today perhaps
devastatingly so
but america already damned by well more
than half the world
polls show at least four billion people
think we're the number one threat to
their security in the world
think about that for a minute
we've already done iraq libya and syria
afghanistan would we we'd just be seen
as continuing the trend besides america
has the military capacity and here's the
long pole in the tent
to project the power needed to unseat
swiftly
the regime in tehran
swiftly in terms of saddam hussein for
example not swiftly in terms of taking
care of 75 million people each one of
which in a very rugged and strategically
deep terrain would want to kill every
damned american in the country
along with probably half the rest of the
arabs in the area
so there's on only one significant hang
up that i see with this strategy that
netanyahu and lieberman are pushing
embroiled in his own legal problems that
just might send him to jail as such
problems would likely have sent arie
sharon to jail had he not been in really
bad shape at the end of his prime
ministership
they're both headed for war
of that i'm convinced
they will use iran's allegedly
existential to israel presence in syria
which is becoming even more so from a
military's perspective every day
hezbollah's accumulation of some 150 000
missiles if we believe our intelligence
agencies
the need to set lebanon's economy back
yet again
that's important look at what they're
deliberating right now with regard to
the
new very very rich gas fine in the
eastern mediterranean with israel
claiming section 9 and lebanon claiming
section 9 take that lebanon we're going
to bomb you then you'll let us have it
and that will be their excuse
and we're looking at them taking on and
this is a point that all military people
understand
a country that couldn't beat iraq
in eight years of brutal bloody war
an iraq that we beat in 19 days
so this is the colossal threat
that they're up against and men such as
h.r mcmaster are helping them the much
heralded author of direct dereliction of
duty
great title and a man who knows about as
much about iran as i do about the eighth
planet in the 95th solar system in the
50th galaxy pass our own
and here's
a hope i have let's hope that the chess
master in chief old vladimir putin he
that ruins elections from paris to
peoria is smart enough once again not to
let this happen
i fear he'll not be and we might have
the stirrings of 1914 as utterly stupid
as we now know those stirrings to have
been
people whom i mentioned such
possibilities people who are critically
analytical and normally fairly sound in
their thinking respond that well don't
you consider that sort of dreary
prognosis
a little bit overdrawn
my rejoinder is usually something a bit
too clever perhaps but along these lines
don't you think a number of people said
that in the summer of 1914
ah they respond but have we not learned
so much since then
i'll yet you be the judge of that and
and inform you only that in my
considered view
we have learned very little and there
are the ingredients right now with
turkey syria iran
iraq
saudi arabia losing dramatically in
yemen right now
and the united states and russia at the
peak of all of this to get engaged a
very distinct possibility
i looked at this from the perspective of
the political parameters
what is it that we're confronting today
in this country and this took me down an
entirely different path as i tried to
figure out just how
this team
of mcmaster tillerson kelly at all and
trump
at the top of it
will face this sort of decision-making
process
and the only place i could find that
remotely resembled where
we are today in our past
was a period 1850 to 1860.
and so about six months ago i started
reading as voraciously as i could on
that period i'd done some reading but i
needed to really do a lot more
it is stunning
the similarities between that period and
now
particularly in the political situation
where one side of the country wouldn't
talk to the other side of the country
and vice versa and i was struck today by
some of the comments that were made that
resemble the comments that were made by
rip my region
my state fired on fort sumter after all
back in those days
and if that is the political situation
in which this government will do its
national security decision making
then we are in deeper trouble than even
the prospects of a region-wide and
perhaps even bigger war
in
the middle east
and the country that will have started
it all the relationship unbalanced as it
is that will have made it possible
this is israel
and that's the danger we face
[Applause]
you were supposed to give us some hope
what happened to that
okay we we are running out of time but
we do have a lot of questions um
but do you want to take one of those or
okay which one we'll do either one okay
[Music]
so
okay this this i want to hear too is
mossad
actively operating in u.s
um institutions versus the power of
aipac and the charitable
israeli institutions wait a minute uh
it's a good question
and
i don't exactly know the answer but um
my sense is that um aipac is effective
enough organization
that
the mossad doesn't have to do its work
there it can confine itself
to the usual intelligence tasks
there is a lot of concern uh in the cia
about the possibility of israeli spying
on the cia
there are pro and
factions within the cia that are have
different views about
israel
but my sense is that it's not the mossad
that does the israeli government's work
in washington it's aipac
okay and this is for colonel wilkerson
what could and would iran do
in response to an attack
this has been war game uh ad nauseam
almost by the u.s military
and there are a number of different
scenarios there's there's one where
the u.s
around the clock three carrier battle
groups bombing
does so much
damage that iran is as you might well
imagine pretty shocked in those 14 to 21
days of bombing much the way
you saw saddam hussein in the first gulf
war
and then iran comes out from the dust so
to speak
counts its casualties uh mans its
hospitals and so forth and essentially
goes into guerrilla war
and that means if we want to do anything
other than just bomb them
which is simply going to drive their
nuclear program underground speed it up
they'll coordinate with the north
koreans they'll have a nuclear weapon in
18 months
and then
watch us hesitate to invade because
that's what they know they'll be doing
by building that weapon we'll have
forced them to make that decision
so if we invade immediately we're going
to be confronting a country that is huge
i've done the war planning for it when
we were planning in the 80s for the
russians to break out of afghanistan and
come on down to chabahar and bondurabas
the two ports the warm water ports we
actually thought that was a possibility
we didn't think the russians came into
afghanistan to just be in afghanistan
then of course they got bogged down
there and couldn't come but it's a tough
country so either way an immediate
invasion is going to take five or six
trillion dollars in 10 years of
occupation to even
begin to say that we're in control of
the country look at iraq
it's one-third the size of iran
and it's going to probably put red
bull's eyes on the back of every soldier
and marine in the country red bull's
eyes that every terrorist group will
flock to to to engage
if we take the other scenario and evade
immediately you're going to have the
same thing but you're going to have it
quicker
and you're going to at least obviate the
possibility that they'll build a nuclear
weapon go underground and build a
nuclear weapon
any thoughts on kushner as an
intelligence effort
and then there's another one the same
all these questions i want to know
any thoughts on assistance israel might
have generated to the trump campaign and
any thoughts on israel's large purchases
of u.s stocks and
possibly to prop up the market
i haven't heard that one uh i don't know
anything about about that uh about that
last uh question
um
jared kushner's so incompetent that it
it doesn't look like the work of any
professional intelligence organization
what he's doing the man is deeply in
debt and desperately trying to figure
out a way how to get out of it
so while he's
very close to the israelis and using
israeli contacts in qatar and saudi
arabia to solve his financial problems i
don't really see intelligence agencies
being involved in that i don't know why
they would want to get involved in that
okay and for colonel wilkerson how far
do you think russia will go and helping
on the side of syria iran etc in the
syrian conflict
how much further i guess the difficulty
there is the imponderable
as van mulkey pointed out
no plan out lasts the first bomb being
dropped
once you start killing russians once you
start shooting su-27s down then they
start shooting f-16s f-15s and f-22s
down you have a whole different
dimension
you've got a real problem then
controlling that escalation theory
says you're probably not going to be
able to control that so that's what
really worries me now
that having been said putin realizes
that and putin has shown that he knows
he doesn't have a whole lot of assets
behind him
compared to the assets that the united
states could bring to bear where it's
serious and so he's been very careful
about the way he moves in the gaps
exploits the moves back and so forth
he's getting ready to do it in kosovo
right now
mitrovica the northern province is being
infiltrated by the serbs watch that
mcmaster and others aren't even aware
it's happening
but he's very smart so the thing that
ought to be happening right now
is that the united states and moscow
despite all this mess that's been
created between us ought to be
cooperating to bring the two parties
that really need to talk to talk
riyadh and tehran
and get them to deal with their problems
diplomatically
and then turn that diplomatic success on
to the syrian conflict which is being
fueled principally by saudi money
with prince bandar in charge
okay here is a question for you morley
um how important was the cooperation
between cia and mossad in places like
central america and and
zaire
um well in the case of uh
central america in the 1980s um there
was a significant israeli role the the
the reagan administration barred from
military aid to counter revolutionary
forces in nicaragua
and restricted in aid to other military
regimes turned to
outside actors their own uh aid network
but also to the israelis to
ship arms ship money
and uh israeli was never clear to me
whether it was a formal israeli
intelligence operation or whether these
were sort of israeli contractors who
were simply allowed to operate in the
region but the the cia and the reagan
administration relied on them quite a
bit um
for
uh what they called counter-terrorism
work for shipping arms and expertise
into the region in order to prevail in
the civil war so in that time uh the
the israeli role was definitely
significant i am not well informed about
the
cia and mossad role in zaire so i can't
really comment on that
okay we have three minutes left i think
um
so based on the
um
this is not a fun question to end the
conference with based on the incredible
um increasing trend of impunity among
aggressive military action like in the
levant
um and genocidal warfare what stops
israel from launching a similar final
solution to the palestinian people
you want me to take that you can either
one of you
i don't
at this point
i don't think lieberman or netanyahu or
any of the more
ultra right-wing
aspects of the zionist political
movement
israeli government whatever we want to
call it or are suicidal
uh i don't think they're that fatalistic
either i i think they really think they
can wind up or some subsequent prime
minister can wind up
with
jordan
with
probably
pieces of syria certainly to go on
and israel can be greater israel and
they're willing to back off from some of
that as powers interpose themselves and
give them a problem with that but they
want a greater israel for a number of
reasons security reasons uh you know the
old biblical prophecies and so forth
um
and so i think they're going to try to
keep this in the air to start with
you're going to see some bombing i think
you're going to see over the next six
months you're going to take them they're
going to take lebanon on they're going
to take hezbollah on in syria and
lebanon
and when that doesn't work or when
hezbollah presents them as they did in
july 2006 with some new options in terms
of what hezbollah can do to them
and maybe even the lebanese armed forces
do too
it might get tricky and then there might
be armored formations ground units
infantry and so forth and that's when
the door opens for general conflict
there was a question asked too but about
the base
here's why i think we put the base there
because the last time i spoke here i
said we didn't have any hard power in
israel so the pentagon responded put the
base there i'm joking i'm joking we put
the base there
for the same reason we have tripwire
forces in other places we put the base
there so that there can be no question
in the minds of the american people when
the president directs u.s forces in to
israel
equipped to go into syria
because we will have been attacked
and the disposition of that base is just
sitting on an israeli air base and we
put the stars and you know the stars and
stripes up and declared it a u.s air
base it's four bat four patriot
batteries as far as i know
but it's there in its u.s territory so
when missiles start flying or
god forbid the irgc actually tries to
put guerrillas into israel proper
then we are being attacked too
and so when we go to congress if trump
feels like he has to go to congress he
isn't going to have to probably congress
is going to be demanding
that the president take action
well that's a very sobering end here
okay another question
we are out of time but uh
one more okay grant you get special
what are the possibilities of a 911
mossad op type strike to propel us into
iran like it did in iraq
who i don't know who wants to take that
i think you've got the ingredients
ingredients right now we have about 3
200 troops in syria you've got secretary
mattis and secretary tillerson both
saying we're staying there because we
need to confront the iranian elements
that are trying to establish this
corridor
and are too close to israel you've got
the president of the united states
contradicting them and saying no when
we've done with isis we're leaving of
course that's an ambiguity when are you
done with isis you could say you're
never going to be done with isis not
completely but it the policy is not
clear right now
but there are all the ingredients in
place including russian u.s aircraft
being conflicted on an hourly basis by
direct communications
you've got all the ingredients for a
wider war and
for a tang like that that suddenly
becomes
you've got the same thing in the south
china sea when the chinese sink a u.s
aircraft carrier what are the american
people going to do when 5 000 souls 14
billion dollars is on the bottom of the
ocean because the chinese are going to
sink a u.s aircraft carrier
guarantee you
what are we going to do or is it going
to be over taiwan are we then going to
defend taiwan
probably not
most americans will probably get anxious
about that
um but this is what we're courting in
the world now at a time when our power
has been dramatically reduced from what
it was in 1945
and we don't recognize that we simply
don't recognize that
too many enemies
okay i think we will end
this panel
and we have a couple um
thank you so much
you have depressed us beyond words
[Applause]